[Music]
I retired a few years ago I had done
25-year service with Tangerine District
Council as a local government officer so
it seemed right that I could take that
experience and that knowledge and take
that into being a counselor
also when my husband and I moved to
Sudbury 22 years ago and we just fell in
love with the area and we wanted to put
something back into it so being a
counselor seeing the obvious choice so I
became a counselor because I found that
I was really passionate about my
community but there were several several
areas where I know people had strong
feelings so antisocial behavior issues
around development things like roads not
being sweet and those sorts of things
and I think it was one of those
situations where you can either sit on
the sidelines and do nothing and
complain or you can literally roll up
your sleeves and get involved so from my
perspective it was something that's very
easy to do everyone comes at it with a
different perspective and especially
what I found quite powerful was that
there are so few young counselors so
they tend to be of a particular age
similar background and actually I think
it was really quite interesting watching
people's reactions saying oh here's
someone who's a little bit younger than
the most local councilors but actually
really cared about their local area and
wants to make it a better place to live
and work I'm a counselor because I was
involved in my community and I wanted to
do more
I was uh on the parish council
um involved in the local church involved
in local business you know I just
enjoy meeting people speaking to them
and trying to help them out where I can
to start with I thought oh no no I can't
possibly do that and then I thought
I don't know there's an awful lot of men
and there's an awful lot of people
traditionally doing it
um so I said oh okay
and I didn't win
I lost about a handful of votes
so obviously when the next session came
round
I thought
so many people had voted for me and I'd
obviously give me the confidence to go
ahead and do it properly which I did and
that time one with a really good
majority so I fell into being a
counselor and people said we are quite
good at this you should do that and
sometimes you think yes I could do that
I stood to make a difference I stood to
make a point I stood to achieve things
that I feel strongly about other kind of
counselor because when I started as a
parish counselor I could see a need at
the district level
and so I put my name forward it was as
simple as that so you're serving you
serve your community which was what my
aim was I got there and I found I'm not
just serving my community but I'm
serving all the communities across the
district
uh helping people with problems casework
we call it you know getting their bins
emptied helping them with the planning
application those sort of things you can
actually make a real difference to
someone and um yeah those are the things
I'm proud of so I had the opportunity
after 35 years of Labor not building or
acquiring new homes we set up a policy
we delivered on a policy that enabled us
to do exactly that so after the last
five years we have actually delivered an
additional
238 homes to provide a house for
somebody that's in need
when my Village lost its shop and its
post office
and the village was what do we do now
and then
I went to my Council and I said you've
got some you've got a small
accommodation
that nobody uses
could I have it please
could I have it for a community shop and
a post office
which they leased to us I mean it's run
by volunteers we needed it to be a safe
place for the Post Office
and I'm thrilled to say that that's now
been going probably 15 years
as a as a local Ward member I represent
five individual villagers and there are
some things that they're very easy to
overlook or ignore if you're a larger
sort of corporate body or entity but
it's things like fixing the roof of a
village hall helping with some speeding
issues on a particular stretch of road
it's a relatively minor things but in
terms of the quality of life for people
living there and that makes a real
difference look government is not just
what's at the top it's local government
Parish councils that's the most
important that's you that's your village
that's your Pub that's your post office
and that's where we need good people and
it's so important because if they like
it and they're good
and they get re-elected then they can
move upwards we need to see a wider
range of people becoming counselors and
you know to be frank a lot of us are a
male pale and stale you know so we need
some younger folk we need people from
different backgrounds who can bring you
know diversity of use to the council and
and perhaps reflect to The Wider Society
we need we need a wide range of people
it's just simply because that's what
Society is
I would definitely like to see more
young people I'd like to see a lot more
diversity amongst the councilors
really really important actually and the
younger people become counselors just
because it is a different perspective I
mean I've seen numerous occasions where
there'll be certain viewpoints certain
perspectives that I haven't been
understood or be misrepresented or
perhaps where the sort of younger voice
and a younger person's perspective isn't
necessarily being given the weight that
I think it should
and it's easy to learn the more effort
you put in the more you get out of it
and the more your community and all the
communities get out of it look for a
place that you can do it a good place to
start and I would recommend this to
anybody in a rural area that just
parishes is to try a parish council few
years ago the Town Council we we joined
a we participated in a shadow in a
counselor scheme it's a central
government scheme so we took we had four
students
and they each had they were assigned one
counselor and they would shadow that
counselor for six months and then it was
great because then they went to London
to get their certificates the house
Department it was fantastic and one of
those young councilors actually stood
for Town Council at a later date to
become a town councilor if you feel
strongly about an issue like I do about
environmental issues that's an
opportunity then to make a difference
come in and help steer your community
and the districts in a slightly
different direction
[Music]
foreign
[Music]